بعد الزلزال والكلام عن اجسام مجهوله
والكائنات الفضائيه صار اي شيء غريب يجنن
العالم طبعا ويرعبهم والخبر اليوم من
اليابان اللي ظهر فجاه على احد شواطئها
الجسم كروي حديدي كبير وما حتفاهم
الجسم هذا شافته السيده على شاطئ ان شعله
المحيط الهادي وبلغت السلطات اللي جاءت
وطوقت المكان ومنعت اي احد يقترب وقفلت
الشاطئ يعني باختصار صارت حاله الطوارئ
لغايه ما يعرفوا ايش هي هذه الكره مستدعوا
خبراء متفجرات تتاكدوا انه لغم او شيء
متفجر او اداه تجسس صينيه او روسيه مثلا
الخبراء قالوا ان الكره قطرها متر ونصف
وانها جوفاء وما هي متفجره ولا شيء لكن
الان مو قادرين يحددوا ايش هي هل هي عوامه
ارساء طفت على سطح الماء ولا ايش بالضبط
ما حد قادر يعرف والدراما زادت لمن ظهر
الرجال وقال يا جماعه قلبتوا الدنيا اليوم
عشان الكوره ليش صار لها شهر على الشاطئ
وما حد عبرها ولا فحصها